Hoy es Día de rezo en este templo
dedicado al candomblé es una religión
que llegó a Brasil de la mano de los más
de cinco millones de esclavos africanos
estamos en la mallada fluminense en la
periferia de Río de Janeiro donde reina
el miedo tras una ola de ataques
violentos contra terrenos como llaman a
esos templos los autores son
narcotraficantes convertidos a la
religión evangélica
son personas que dicen no quiero que el
viva más aquí ahora quien vive
aquí es Dios nosotros seríamos el
demonio
esta religiosa da voz a quienes están
amenazados de muerte a pesar de su
perfil militante reconoce que tiene
miedo
mis amigos me dicen hermana sal de aquí
esto es peligroso no sigas denunciando
los ataques
para este estudioso detrás de la
intolerancia religiosa está el racismo
estructural
Este es un proyecto de estado es un
proyecto político hegemónico que quiere
que los cristianos sean hegemónicos que
sean la comunidad que pueda gozar de
todos sus derechos mientras que las
otras religiones como el espiritismo la
onda y el candomblé están fuera de ese
proyecto
pero un sector de los evangélicos se
opone a tanta violencia
clever es una estrella de la música
gospel cantó la investidura del
presidente Lula su apoyo explícito a las
religiones de matriz africana le ha
costado varios ataques por partes de sus
fans antes de ser cristiano Soy un
hombre negro que creció en una Favela yo
fui criado en un ambiente muy plural
desde el momento en que veo en la
sociedad siendo una figura pública
templos atacados Víctimas de la
intolerancia religiosa no puedo quedarme
callado
es el ejemplo vivo de que no todos los
evangélicos son intolerantes ni se
identifican con el fundamentalismo
religioso